so donald trump's ambassador to the
united nations nikki haley
is resigning at the end of the year this
was announced yesterday
uh trump and nikki haley actually did a
press event
at the white house and it was all
presented as everybody's on good terms
this is all very happy nikki's great
everybody's great
uh but the truth is that nikki haley has
actually been pretty critical
of donald trump during her tenure as
ambassador to the un at least compared
to
some of the other totally uh uh
unconscious
brown nosers of donald trump and
according to what
trump said yesterday he had known for
six months that nikki haley
wanted a break after this year and
everybody is just super happy about this
is what we were led to believe but we
know that haley was sometimes at odds
with trump's
third of three national security
advisers
uh john bolton and this is number one a
decision a change that is likely going
to lead to
even more radicalization and it's not
that nikki haley was
pro-un in any broad sense of the term by
no means but
she is likely more friendly to the
united nations than whoever donald trump
is going to end up naming as her
replacement
and yesterday i did the story about the
radicalization
of american institutions and what we're
seeing is that american diplomacy
continues to radicalize when you add as
trump certainly will a more hostile to
the united nations ambassador
you are furthering this move to the
right this radicalization of american
diplomacy
now as far as what the real the
so-called real plan
is here there's a bunch of different
speculation i'll tell you
some of the top hypotheses number one
there's the suggestion that there's
going to be a really big shakeup
in the trump administration for 2020 and
that nikki haley
will ultimately run as trump's vice
president
for 2020 for the re-election campaign as
his running mate and that mike pence
will end up going to the cabinet right
this is this is not what i think is
going to happen necessarily but this is
one idea
another idea is that nikki haley is
being groomed
to run for the senate in 2020
in south carolina and there's actually
some specific details about that i got
one email saying
trump is going to push chief of staff
john kelly out
after the midterms meaning in december
january
and install nikki haley as chief of
staff which
doesn't ring particularly true to me
given that again
nikki haley has been somewhat critical
of some things that donald trump has
said and done
another idea would be that the reason
for nikki haley
leaving her un ambassadorship is
so that lindsey graham who's a senator
from south carolina
can be rewarded for that totally
unhinged brett kavanaugh
rant at the hearings two weeks ago and
as u.n ambassador you then put nikki
haley in
as senator filling in for lindsey graham
for the remainder of his term
and then she runs in 2020 in 2020
lindsey graham's seat is up for
re-election
and you would get her the power of
incumbency by having her in there for a
couple of years
and then she can actually run for that
seat properly as as the
actual candidate um in 2020 but for me
the most interesting possibility has
nothing to do with trump's plan for
nikki haley
it just so happens pat i don't know if
you'll be surprised by this i know many
in our audience won't be
that nikki haley's resignation
announcement remember she's not actually
leaving till the end of the year
came the day after an ethics watchdog
group
requested an investigation into her
flights on private jets
the watchdog group is claiming that she
improperly disclosed i think it's six or
seven
flights on private jets on her 2017
financial disclosure
a lot of problems with private jet and
first-class
jet travel for trump people and this is
interesting timing to say the least this
is completely in line with what tom
price did and what steve mnuchin did
but it could all just be coincidence i
mean this will be two full years for
nikki haley as the un ambassador yeah
it's not like
at the beginning of the trump
administration when people would leave
after a month or two
and we were wondering why are they
leaving so early i think there are fewer
questions with this one
there are fewer questions but there are
still questions
and uh we know that a really good way to
get
federal ethics probes to go away is to
resign
now she's not actually leaving until the
end of the year and how that would play
into a possible ethics investigation is
less clear
but citizens for responsibility and
ethics in washington has filed a
complaint
they want a full investigation into this
they want the inspector general to
explore
these seven flights on private jets
paid for by three south carolina
businessmen did she resign yesterday or
announce her resignment
resignation yesterday because of this i
don't know what i do know
is that it's too easy to get out of
these ethics investigations by resigning
that that's
in no other world are you free to go
like if you get into your car before the
police
catch you and say we want to talk to you
about something you say
i made it into my car the police don't
say oh you know you did
you're in your car we're not going to
talk to you we're not going to explore
what it is we think you did wrong
that's basically the way it works with
federal officials and these ethics
investigations so anyway
which is the most likely explanation i
don't know
but nikki haley is going bye-bye and
there are important policy implications
which is
which relate to the question of how
trump
is going to have a replacement influence
the relationship of the united states
with the un
which to use trump's word is an
increasingly beleaguered
relationship and this really matters and
lastly let me throw in
could donald trump be thinking of
replacing
nikki haley with his own daughter
not tiffany he seems to can't he seems
he can't stand tiffany at all
ivanka trump could ivanka trump be
trump's idea
of the next ambassador to the united
nations
he couldn't they wouldn't let him right
well
let's talk about that next